this is one of those fun
questions but uh where would you put it
in in the uh ranking of the greatest
breakthroughs in artificial intelligence
history
so like okay so let's let's see who's in
the running
maybe you can correct me so you got like
alpha zero and alpha go
beating you know beating the world
champion at the game of go
thought to be impossible like 20 years
ago
or at least the ad community was highly
skeptical
then you got like also deep blue
original kasparov
you have deep learning itself like the
maybe what would you say the alexnet
image in that moment so the first you'll
network at
achieving human level performance super
not
that's not true achieving like a big
leap in performance
on the computer vision problem uh there
is
open ai the whole like gpt-3
that whole space of transformers and
language models just achieving this
incredible
performance uh of application of neural
networks to
language models boston dynamics pretty
cool
like robotics even though people are
like there's no ai
no no there's no machine learning
currently
but ai is much bigger than machine
learning yes
so so that just the engineering aspect i
would say is one of the greatest
accomplishments in engineering
side engineering meaning like mechanical
engineering
of uh robotics ever then of course
autonomous vehicles you can argue for
waymo
which is like the google self-driving
car or you can
argue for tesla which is like actually
being used
by hundreds of thousands of people on
the road today machine learning system
um and uh i don't know if you can
what else what what else is there but i
think that's it so and then
alpha four many people are saying as up
there potentially number one
would you put them at number one well in
terms of the
impact on on the science and
on the society beyond it's definitely
you know
to me would be one of the you know uh
to answer that you know but you know i
uh you know i
i do have i i remember my you know
uh back in i think 1997
when deep blue that kasparov
it was i mean it was a shock
i mean it was and i think for the for
the
you know uh for the
you know uh pre-substantial
part of the world that especially
people who have some uh you know
some experience with chess right and
realizing how
incredibly human this game how you know
how much of a brain power you need
you know to to reach those you know
those levels of uh grand masters right
level
and it's probably one of the first time
and how good caspar was
and again yeah so caspar is actually one
of the best
ever right and you get a machine that
beats him
right so it's it's first time a machine
probably beat a human at
that scale of a thing of anything yes
yes so that was to me that was like you
know one of the groundbreaking
events in the history of ai that's
probably number one that's
probably like we don't it's hard to
remember it's like muhammad ali versus
uh
i don't know any other mike tyson or
something like that it's like nah
you got to put muhammad ali at number
one uh same with
same with d blue even though it's not
machine learning based
uh i still it it uses advanced search
and search is the integral part of a
yeah right so it's not you said
people don't think of it that way not at
this moment in vogue currently
search is not seen as a as a fundamental
aspect of intelligence but it very well
i mean very likely is in fact i mean
that's what neural networks are
they're just performing search on the
space of parameters and it's all search
all of intelligence is some form of
search and you just have to become
clever and clever at that search problem
you